this is a special experiment that Neal
has wanted to do for nearly 40 years
he saw it done by his teacher and he's
always wanted to repeat it the
experiment is very simple it consists of
a test tube in a test tube rack filled
nearly to the top with diethyl ether the
point about diethyl ether is that it's
very volatile its boiling point is just
above room temperature and so you can
get it to evaporate by blowing air
through it but it's better to use
nitrogen because it's pretty inflammable
think for a moment why atoms in the gas
phase form a liquid and they form a
liquid because the atoms or molecules
are attracted to each other and they're
attracted to a denser state which is a
liquid so when you evaporate the liquid
you have to put in energy to pull those
molecules apart and because diethyl
ether is not a very high boiling point
liquid you don't have to put in all that
much energy but you still have to put in
some energy and it comes from the
temperature of the ether and from the
temperature of the room so what happens
is as you blow the nitrogen through the
test tube it starts cooling down if you
didn't have the nitrogen the vapor which
is quite heavy will just sit in the top
of the test tube and no more evaporation
would take place so the nitrogen is
stirring things up and blowing the vapor
away now
niall got a bit bored because it was
rather slow turned up the flow of
nitrogen and you can see really
beautifully how the ether vapor comes
out of the top of the test tube
and because it's heavier than air and
it's cold it then floats down the side
of the test tube with the thermal
imaging you can see this vapor really
nicely with the naked eye you can see
nothing as the liquid evaporates you
need to put in the so-called latent heat
of vaporization to get the vapor to come
out we're not having any source of heat
so the heat is coming from the liquid
itself in its temperature drops so if
you look at the thermal image
you can see the color of the ether
changing as it gets colder and colder
and the scale is on the side of the
picture now the part that Neel really
remembers is that after the teacher had
done this experiment for a bit he
squirted some water onto the outside of
the test tube now remember the test tube
is pretty cold so the water cooled down
and actually froze so ice was formed in
a pool at the bottom of the outside of
the test tube and not only was it formed
but effectively sealed or glued the test
tube to the test tube rack and the image
that really stuck in Neil's mind was his
teacher mr. Mansur lifting up the test
tube and the whole rack coming with it
Neil thinks it's pretty remarkable that
you can freeze water just by the
evaporation the ether I'm slightly less
surprised because in one lab where is
working somebody dropped a whole large
bottle of ether and it splashed on his
trousers and the evaporation nearly
froze his legs another technician
dropped a bottle of ether he caught fire
and burnt off his eyebrows but that's
another story
we thank Google's making and science
initiative for helping us make this
video if you want more information about
the initiative look down in the video
description
[Music]